and they use that to buy paid up
additions that is not the same as
keeping your cash value that's buying
extra insurance with your overpayment
you know what a paid up addition is a
paid up addition is buying additional
insurance
getting more at death not because you
got your cash value but because you used
your policy dividends to buy additional
Insurance well let's just do a little
present value calculation on what you
put in for a baby five thousand dollars
a year for 13 years do you know what
that would be in a mutual fund
at age 88 it would be 25 million dollars
dude well he's going to have that anyway
instead of putting it into this rip-off
thing and making four percent on your
money and when he dies he loses his cash
value if you put this in a good mutual
fund you'd have a hundred X 10x the
amount of money and that's your infinite
freaking Bank